it's good to see you welcome glad to
have you
um it's been a while it's good to see
people with their faces actually
for a change um
we haven't seen you for a while but
we've been busy in the meantime
the college being the campus here hasn't
really shut down
quite at all first we operated as an
essential business
then as a religious institution and then
there was an exemption for libraries as
well so we found a way
at every moment we kept the classes
going and we kept
uh our programs going we're very happy
to welcome all of you back and
this is our second lecture but we're off
to the races
um so welcome good to have you here uh
the graduate school uh that we launched
a bit ago is uh on going on two years
now is we
kept that going as well and it's off to
a great start we've got a great round of
of students we have some renovations
planned for
this building you can see in the
washington parlor afterwards we can if
you want to take a look at those
uh so we are keeping keeping going a
pace
uh and busy as always uh this week we
actually put something else new out
which i wanted to mention before
uh we get to our speaker for those of
you know
at the end of last year being of this
year i was briefly on leave as the
executive director of the 1776
commission
i was fired so
it was a pretty good gig while it lasted
but i kept my day job and i'm back
uh but hillsdale college took up that
mantle
uh among other things the commission is
kept meeting
we met here actually despite having been
abolished
but the college took on its part of that
work
because the commission asked and called
on
the creation of accurate and good honest
historical curriculum this
week actually just a few days ago
hillsdale college has released
to the public free of charge to anybody
who wants to use it a parent
a school a homeschooler a school
district
a full curriculum covering civics
and all of american history having with
the founding and the civil war era
and that's free for anybody's use
we know what we're against we think it's
important to also know what we're for
uh this evening we are privileged to
have with us
and we were talking earlier and i'm very
much looking forward to his talk
the former acting the commissioner of
the u.s customs and border protection
in the trump administration he's
currently a visiting fellow at the
heritage foundation
he has a bs in engineering from central
missouri state
university and a jd from the university
of missouri kansas city
he also served as
the chief of the u.s border patrol in
the obama administration
and the director of the u.s immigration
customs enforcement
he is a former active member of and a
reserve from the united states marine
corps
and he served over 20 years he's got a
very impressive and amazing career
over 20 years in the fbi in a various
variety of positions he was an assistant
section chief for the national center
for analysis of violent crime branch
he was deputy on the scene commander in
baghdad
iraq a special agent in charge of the el
paso division
and assistant director in charge of the
fbi academy in quantico virginia just
down the highway
uh it's a very impressive career and
thank you for that service to your
country
this evening he is speaking on the
crisis
at our southern border please join me in
welcoming mark
[Applause]
morgan
first of all thanks most time i don't
need a mic
a little bit um so first of all thanks
for
allowing me to come here and give me a
few minutes to talk about
the crisis at the southern border um
first of all i think that
um engagements like this are very very
important
because the message is not getting out
there the truth
and the reality and the transparent it
simply doesn't exist
and when matt when when matt first
reached out and by the way matt is
if i go a little long just give me the
five minute hook okay because because
because at the end i really do want to
hear from you too i want to hear your
questions
it really helps me kind of shape going
forward what you think is important
and quite frankly the misinformation
that continues to go out there it's
important for me to know
but when matt first reached out he
referred to it as
the crisis at the southern border and
i i really like that because as you go
one of my main themes
is going to be that it is about a crisis
as a southern border it's not just
about illegal immigration and i'll talk
i'll talk a little bit about that as i
go on so look
first of all i'm speaking today because
this country
is in the midst of an undeniable crisis
on our southwest border plain and simple
that's the fact
that's the reality it's a crisis with
respect to our sovereignty
it's a crisis with respect to our
security and our future
in just a few short months the biden
administration
and this is key has intentionally and
methodically
a man-made crisis at our southern border
they've done this by
purposely undoing every single
meaningful
uh security tool authority and policy
that we had in place
under the trump administration and let
me just a couple of facts i think that
speaks for themselves
four straight months of 170 000
illegal aliens per month the june
numbers just came out
almost 190 000
apprehensions of illegal aliens in a
single month
that is the highest that's the third
highest monthly totals
in over 21 years and once
illegal aliens break into our country
and here illegally and they're released
under this administration
they're not deported why because they
have all but
gutted ice with respect to their
enforcement authorities
i've been saying since the beginning
they're creating a welcoming center on
the front end
and a sanctuary country on the back end
never in this country's history has our
national security
been harmed and targeted for the sole
purpose
of political gain i'm often asked
to talk about my perspective on border
security and
the undeniable illegal immigration
crisis that we have on our southwest
border
but here's an issue and i started off
with this is that
the print that very premise of how we
look at border security and illegal
immigration
really is is faulty it's generated on
misguided uninformed and forces the
american people into a false binary
choice
and today's politically charged
ideological charge environment
you know most of our collective
bandwidth it goes something like this
it's about the plight of immigrants
looking for a better life and so what
that does is that binary choice it
forces us into binary choice that
that if if we don't accept the end
justifies the means
and the policies responsible for driving
the worst
southwest border crisis we see in modern
history
is is separate and distinct from
securing our border
that's just not true um that the reality
is
when policies open our borders to
blatantly incentivize encourage
and facilitate i used to say
incentivizing courage in this
administration i'm actually
adding another adjective facilitate
illegal immigration
our borders across the board
also become increasingly less secure
and more vulnerable to the ever-changing
vast complex set of threats
that we face from outside our borders
the threats are
not mutually exclusive from each other
but the open border advocates in this
administration are forcing us into this
binary choice
um when when we so when we discuss
illegal immigration
it's essential that we do so with an
understanding of how it's synonymous
with border security and at its core
illegal immigration also serves a
broader national interest
it's about the rule of law we were just
talking about that a few minutes ago
it's about protecting our national
security and our public safety
it's about protecting american wages and
jobs that list can go on and on
with respect to the broad national
interests that it serves
and the threats that we face here's
another false narrative that's out there
that they really try to force down
and this is another important element in
addition to the fact that
border security is not separate from
illegal immigration
is that the threats that we face on our
southern border quite frankly any of our
borders
do not stay at the southwest border they
make their way into
every neighborhood in our country that's
why i've been saying for a long time
every town city and state is actually a
border town city and state
the um the criminal organizations
look they are sophisticated and they
exploit
every single gap that's available
through weak
ambiguous and faulty u.s policy
and this is important when our policies
strengthen
a criminal organization's ability to
facilitate
one criminal activity it strengthens
their ability
to facilitate every single criminal
activity
coming to our borders look it's very
clear
as they get stronger and more powerful
and their bank accounts grow
because of the profits from illegal
immigration from human trafficking
i mean human smuggling their their
ability to
increase and expand uh their capability
with respect to human trafficking goes
up smuggling of gang members goes up
smuggling
criminal aliens goes up drugs pouring
into this country
goes up it's just common sense these
organizations are sophisticated
and over decade after decade they've
proven their capacity and ability
to shift their what we call ttps tactics
tactics techniques and procedures
with the shift of american policy laws
and regulations
and they do so effectively look they
don't see
they see 20 pounds of methamphetamine
just as they see 20 illegal aliens
that they're smuggling in the united
states it's a commodity
and all they see is their ability to
increase their profit their leverage
their power their influence and their
strength
and when you allow their criminal scheme
one criminal scheme to increase you're
absolutely increasing their profit
leverage power influence and strength
and as u.s right now law enforcement
agencies
are being forced to deal with this this
unmitigated crisis on a southwest border
um you've got in in multiple areas along
the southwest border you have 40 to 50
percent of the border resources on the
front lines of our borders they're being
pulled away
to deal with the unprecedented
humanitarian crisis the unprecedented
volume think about it
a hundred and ninety thousand illegal
aliens
in 30 day period think about just from a
common sense perspective
you don't have to be border security
expert the the the
extraordinary resources and manpower
that it takes
to apprehend those individuals process
them and give them the appropriate
humanitarian assistance they need
sometimes i i refer to it and i'm not
off
as daycare assistants as well that's
just the fact that's the truth i had a
border
real quick i had more trades when i was
still chief of the border troll i went
down there and i
visited a facility it looked like a
costco it really did
i mean from floor to ceiling the
ceilings were higher than this
and their shelves all the way up baby
formula baby diapers
clothes you know that were labeled from
you know zero to two two to four and et
cetera and at the border choice in
almost 20 years said you know sir i
never thought in my entire career that
my major responsibility would be to
procure
baby formula and diapers that's what
they're being utilized for
so if you think about that if you've got
40 or 50 percent of border troll
resources being pulled off the line
again i would say
common sense tells you there's large
areas of the border that are wide open
and not secure and this i keep going
back to this you don't have to see
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
to see that correlation that i was
talking about
having over a million illegal immigrants
attempt to
illegally in our southwest border in
just a few months overwhelms our
frontline
defenses overwhelms our resources pulls
them off the front line
and creates the perfect storm for the
cartels to exploit
not only not only are they profiting
from the increased
human smuggling efforts because of the
open board policies
but which is by the way a multi-billion
dollar industry for them each year
annually
but they're also using the very uh
humans
that they are exploiting and illegally
entering
to profit from other schemes they
actually literally will say
okay you know what uh we're gonna charge
you five thousand dollars we'll in just
in this
here's his backpack of drugs put it on
your back you're going across with the
drugs happens
every single day and every single one of
the nine sectors
on the southwest border um they actually
will use
the the the individuals the migrants
that that they're trafficking and
and smuggling across i call them as
distraction ponds knowing that the
border troll resources are going to have
to respond to unaccompanied minors and
families they'll actually flood an area
of about 20 50 families knowing all the
border troll resources will go there
again don't have to be rocket scientists
or border security expert to know then
right next to them physically
the border is wide open drugs are
pointing across gangs members are
pouring across
illegal aliens are pouring across um
so again you you facilitate one it makes
it exponentially easier
and the likelihood of other uh criminal
schemes happening
and one big thing we were talking about
this a minute ago got aways
got aways we don't talk about that a
godaway
is someone that that because border tour
resources are pulled away because our
borders are not secured
they get past our our uh first line of
defense
uh with uh on the southwest border so
right now and i'm looking for the the
details here
so um where am i at so they
yeah so um right now it's estimated that
that
here it is fiscal year today the
godaways
270 got aways this fiscal year
270 000 they have gotten past
the border troll resources because
they're pulled off the line providing
the humanitarian assistance
and here's where um that that i think
in today's environment you know politics
ideology drive the narrative rather than
facts
and usually this is where the ideologues
will will jump up and call me a
fear-monger and call me a racist
as they stick their heads deeply in the
sand to avoid the truth and reality
is of those 270 000 by the way
that that's larger than the city of
arlington virginia
right this fiscal year 270 000 among
them
are some really bad people that's the
truth
they're not all good now they're not all
bad but they're not all good
there is a con and the numbers of bad
are not statistically inconsequential
they are consequential and in that group
of the 270
000 that have gotten by are criminals
rapists
child pedophiles other violent uh
uh uh predators and yeah even people
have been convicted of dui's
which a lot of times people want to
dismiss even though it's killed ten
thousand american
citizens annually um that's the truth
and that's the reality but when was the
last time you heard the mainstream media
talk about the 270 000 godaways
have you ever heard it right i was going
to say most of you probably even heard
that
that number and and i'll go back to what
i started with
is that what happens on the border
doesn't stay in the border
right those 270 000 they're not staying
on the southwest border townsend city
the the the border is the throughput
they're making their way into every town
city and state
in this country and let me give you a
couple more stats in the pas
first of all in the past decade border
troll loan has rep had operated
tens of thousands of criminal aliens
that's who they've apprehended
right this year alone they evaporated
over 8 000
criminal aliens 8 000 and gang members
rapists pedophiles i always ask somebody
how many is enough
to let in the united states what 100
gang members
a thousand gang members how many rapists
and murders
and i'm not i'm not exaggerating that's
the truth and that's the fact
i'll give you another stat that backs it
up ice alone last year 2020
ice apprehended a hundred thousand
that's a low year cove and some other
elements played a factor in that they
rested a hundred
thousand uh um they made a hundred
thousand arrests last year
for people that were here in the country
illegally and remember ice isn't on the
border they're in the ontario united
states everywhere in the united states a
hundred thousand
ninety percent of them either had been
convicted of a criminal
of a crime or had been charged 90
of them that's another false nerve
that's out there that gets me fired up
is that this you know they've reset the
the ice priorities
uh quote to go after uh priority targets
they already are
you know a criminal if you're here
illegally
and you're a criminal i don't care what
you're charged with you should be a
priority
not this administration this
administration has to be a known
suspected terrorist
or convicted convicted of an aggravated
felony
to actually be a priority for ice to uh
actually remove you
um yeah so
look and let me i'll go here a little
bit here so so
look they and as all this is going on
again what one
one criminal activity is connected to
another they're interconnected it's all
about border security
what happens is the southwest border
doesn't stay on the southwest border in
addition to that
as the cartels are are reaping their
money look
the bite administration immediately when
they open their borders and turn human
smuggling back on
they turned a multi-billion dollar
business back on
for the cartels what do you think
they're going to do with that look
they're going to take that money
to facilitate more sophistic techniques
they're going to improve their capacity
to build tunnels
to use drones ultra lights maritime
operations it goes
on and on and that's just in between the
ports of entry
at the ports of entry i i could say for
two hours to talk about the different
techniques
that they use to smuggle drugs through
our legal points of entry
and why are they able to do that because
they're they're one of the most advanced
sophisticated well-funded organizations
right now in the world and right now
it's because this administration has
turned on
their human uh smuggling capabilities i
used to joke around a little bit but but
i'm serious when i say
you know the cartels could come to
harvard and teach a cl well they could
come to hillsdale
and and and teach a class on on business
resiliency and flexibility
uh they're they're that good and so the
point being here is
look if you have one element of our
border that is
out of control every element of our
border is out of control
you can't separate you can't just say
that our borders out of control for
illegal immigration
but it's secure for everything else it
doesn't work that way
it's all interconnected so if you're out
of control with your illegal immigration
which clearly you are it's out of
control with drugs it's out of control
with human trafficking it's out of
control with gangs
and criminal aliens and our national
security it's all out of control if one
element's out of control
and look ronald reagan it's a quote i
love it a nation
that cannot control its borders is not a
nation
i couldn't have said it better myself so
if we we can't be swayed
um by those that are be driven by what i
call
ideologic hubris and the quest for
perpetual political power
that's what i say the current and look i
know we see this i know we all do i
have to believe this i want to believe
this that we all see the the clear
abundant hypocrisy that's happened with
this administration
look it wasn't long ago with this
country face the worst terrorist
incident
in our nation's history we came together
in a bipartisan
uh way on multiple fronts back then and
i'll give you one quick example
the 2000 secure fence act i won't ask
for hands but i'm just curious how many
have actually heard
about the 2006 secure fence act it was a
bipartisan effort okay a couple of hands
right
it it actually got overwhelming support
in the senate
and here here's here's what the secure
fence act said it mandated
that dhs followed the tried and true
test that
actually codified the multi-layer
strategy of technology personnel and
infrastructure
and infrastructure is the wall right
and and it all gets better ironically
the secure fence act
actually goes into detail and says and
talks about that you will build two
layers of infrastructure it will have
access roads and sensors and lighting
and it goes on and on
sound familiar it's exactly what we were
doing on the trump administration
and in fact the secure fence act led to
650 miles of wall being built
in the trump administration we were just
building it better
that's the truth and let me tell you so
so we had
because this is important with respect
to the with respect to the hypocrisy
that the act gained resounding support
from
prominent congressional members senator
then
biden clinton carper durbin
feinstein kerry obama schumer i could
keep going on
these are all individuals that voted for
the 2000 secure fence act
that mandated that that the dhs build a
wall
that resulted in two 650 miles of wall
being built
from 2006 to 2011
right so what i think this shows is
a couple of things one is traditionally
there has at least been
some illusion that we've been agree
agreed regardless of what party
that border security was important but i
think it also shows that unconscionable
undeniable
hypocrisy and lies that are being told
and let me let me give you a couple of
quotes
and i looked this up i could i i there
are volumes of quotes that i could give
but there's just a couple i want to
share with you
this is what was said we simply cannot
allow people to
pour in the united states undetected
undocumented
unchecked circumventing the line of
people who are waiting patiently
diligently and lawfully to become
immigrants in this country
sounds pretty reasonable doesn't it
sounds like something president trump
would say
right guess who senator barack obama
right i voted numerous times when i was
senator
to spend money to build a wall a barrier
to try to prevent illegal immigrants
from coming in
nope not trump hillary clinton
illegal immigration is wrong plain and
simple
people who enter the united states
without permission are
illegal aliens and illegal aliens should
not be treated the same
as people who enter the united states
illegally now that sounds like something
president trump would say right
nope senator chuck schumer to
2009 he gave a speech to georgetown
university
three years after he voted for the
secure fence act that was
at that very time building wall on our
southwest border
and during that speech he's bragging
about the 2000 secure fence act
calling the illegal aliens illegally
aliens what they are
and and talking about how effective the
wall is
i really encourage everybody that
there's about i think it's about 12
minutes
2009 georgetown university google it
watch it
the hypocrisy will be a parent
here's the last one uh yeah i voted for
a fence
i voted for 700 miles of fence and let
me tell you something folks
people are driving across that border
with tons tons hear me
tons of everything from methamphetamine
to cocaine to heroin
it's all coming up through corrupt
mexico
who said that joe biden right
so now now now so so statements made by
by both republican and democrat
presidents congressional members
uh in the past has illustrated that that
traditionally we have all been united
uh when it comes to border security uh
but clearly it shows the hypocrisy
you know president trump his border
security uh and immigration policies the
past four years been called hard line
right
immoral and racist when in reality the
the very phrases that they're labeling
as
racist or hard line are
indistinguishable
from what the democrats have been saying
prominent democrats have been saying
and that's why i get fired up about
about the hypocrisy
and somehow you know look i get really
frustrated because somehow these
strongly held democratic beliefs
um were supposedly as american as apple
pie just a few years ago
have been replaced with a new version of
what is moral just in american way
the 650 miles that were built from 2006
to 2011
that were this in absolutely deeded
impediment
to to reduce the flow of illegal
immigration a significant barrier
by chuck schumer if he bragged about it
is now immoral and effective
in fact the first bullet point of
biden's dhs appropriation plan
uh he says no wall no no no no money for
the wall
so look um clearly border security
and illegal immigration have become one
of the most politically
driven emotionally charged and
ideologically based uh issues in recent
history
i've been serving this country in the
bio for
for 35 years under six different
administrations both republican and
democrat
and this does not bring me pleasure to
say but in those 35 plus years six
administrations republican democrat
i have never seen administration so
blatantly
um lie to the american people is this
administration
um it almost virtually
everything with respect to border
security and immigration
coming out of this administration is a
lie it's absolutely not
rooted in reality or the truth
and it's it look right now they're
they're they're they're changing
um you know how are mer they're they're
wanting to change i think what are our
american values
to fit neatly into their current
narrative uh as part of their strategy
for permanent political power
uh they simply are making up their own
reality
uh they're changing history they're
intentionally driving false narratives
and forcing american people to again
accept misleading binary choices
you either want to help poor immigrants
with a better life or you're
uncompassionate
uncaring uh racist that's the binary
choices they're trying to force american
people
and they won't accept a rational
discussion the tax on the administration
have been relentless we all saw for the
past four plus years and the attacks
continue
by the current secretary of dhs ali
mayorkas
um who continues to i mean it's
he's almost defiant and arrogant uh with
some of the stuff he's saying like for
example the lies
that our borders are closed um and our
borders are secure
it's just absurd look you don't have to
be a a border security expert
to know this for what it is it's a
feeble attempt to tell american people
we're not seeing what we're seeing
with our own eyes a hundred and ninety
thousand
in a single month two hundred and
seventy thousand got aways
uh if if you include the the
the apprehensions the guidaways and the
turnbacks those who
go to the border and they're about to be
apprehended and they go back to mexico
i mean already you look at 1.5 million
people that have attempted to illegally
enter our borders
but our borders are closed our borders
are secure
right it's it right it's absurd but
they're still peddling that
um and they're they're still hoping
american people are gonna
buy so rather than take full
responsibility uh for
creating this crisis the secretary
continues to lie
um and especially i think what really
gets me is he's lying to the very men
and women on the front lines
that he has now put in harm's way to to
address
the unsecured unmitigated disaster on
the border that they
they uh created another thing look i'm
often asked
you know am uh am i frustrated with
what's happened on the southwest border
well clearly i am um right of course i
am
you know i i've had to watch with with
all of you with the entire
american people as the administration
systematically dismantled
every single effective tool and
authority that we put in place
you know a network of policies
initiatives which regained
integrity back in the system it closed
significant loopholes
that were there it applied legitimate
and reasonable consequences
it effectively reduced the flow of
illegal aliens it resulted in
unprecedented cooperation with our
foreign partners in mexico
and beyond and the northern triangle
countries and to provide the tools and
resources to the men women on the front
lines to secure
our borders and this administration with
a stroke of a political pin
got rid of it all and then what did they
do they blame the trump administration
we're not buying it and that's another
reason why i'm here and i'm going to
continue to be heard
because what they're peddling is
absolute absurdity
and it's it's pure lies um look the
truth is
the biden administration inherited the
most secure borders
in our history that's a fact now does it
mean they were 100
secure no but they were the most secure
that we've had
and they were getting more secure and
more effective every single day
because of trump's policies because of
those network
of tools authorities and policies but
look
my frustration doesn't just stem that
they open up all the loopholes they
return
catch and release they've created the
worst illegal immigration crisis on our
southwest border making our borders
more vulnerable less secure and i've
already gone on a lot about that
but but what is equally frustrating me i
think you're seeing the theme is
they from day one they're lying to you
everything that they tell you about what
they're doing and why they're doing it
and how they're doing it
is a lie look i'll give you an example
so when they could no longer
you know keep the media at bay about the
crowded overcrowded border troll
facilities that we're seeing on
southwest border
it came to 2019 right but the difference
is we were trying to stop it and fix it
right they're continuing to encourage it
well so they know
that the political optics were bad
border troll facilities were overcrowded
right so this is when the by
administration came up what i call their
their shell game their ponzi scheme
right
give an example so in donna texas border
troll facilities were there
overcrowded unaccompanied minors right
in there
dangerously crowded it was bad shouldn't
be there
it's about all the way around well what
they did was
they built a temporary hhs facility
right literally like i think it was
25 40 yards away i'm not making it up
look up 25 40 yards away at 800 million
dollars
of your money to build the hhs facility
and then one day to address political
optics not to address
or stem the flow of illegal immigration
not to do a single thing
to stop these people from giving them
hard-earned money and their lives over
the hands of cartels to be
smuggled no that's not why it was to
address political optics
they literally walked the unaccompanied
minors thousands of them
right from the overcrowded border
facility the 40 yards across
the way into the hhs facility and then
they brought the cameras
where to the border troll facilities and
said look nothing to see here everything
under control
complete [ __ ] i'm sorry
right right
[Applause]
yeah sorry about that um so
actually it's pretty good i've only said
one cut word so far so
um and so when you look at that
so not only am i frustrated about
actually physically
that our national security is being
jeopardized but also that they're lying
about it
um another incredible false narrative
they try to get the american people to
believe
is i'm sure you heard it but nothing to
see here
this is about seasonal change right we
always see this
you know after the winter the numbers go
up but then the summer the numbers will
go down
in fact all the way up to change from
secretary mayorkas to the press
secretary to the president united states
all said this to us right and i laughed
every single time i got out there and
said they're lying just wait
and what do we see june 190 000.
and oh by the way when they were saying
that in april
we at the time they were saying that
trying to shove that down the american
people
we were experiencing a 900
increase from the same time last year so
why we're seeing a 900 increase
and by the way the the best seasonal
change i think has been maybe 15 percent
from month-to-month flows and we're
seeing a 900 increase and they're trying
to jam that down
and then what do we see in june 190 000
and there's no end in sight
so i don't believe any any any
intellectually
honest person believes that lie going
forward as well
then real quick so 2019 how how how did
we address the
the the crisis in 2019
look we we we saw uh uh you know that
historically immigration has been a
problem for decades but the last decade
or so
there were several things that were
happening there was just nonsensical
legislation
there was judicial activism uh that that
was uh
happening as well as what what we think
unconstitutional executive orders and
let me let me talk to you
there's lots out there but let me talk
to you about a couple of the big ones tv
pra
draft trafficking victims protection
reauthorization act
this is a piece of nonsensical
legislation legislation half of it half
of it made sense others didn't
it says that if you're from a contingent
country and you're not identified as
unaccompanied minors being trafficked
we're going to send you back to mexico
and canada to be reunited with your
family
makes sense guess what the other half of
that law
said if you're from outside of mexico or
canada
and you're not identified as being
trafficked and you're unaccompanied
minor
we keep you how does that make sense
i actually traveled to all three
northern triangle countries i spoke to
leaders of all those countries
and every single one of them said to me
unilaterally and separate
why are you keeping our kids why are you
keeping the future of our country
can you please change your laws that if
they're not trafficked can you return
them to their families
so they can come back home it just
doesn't make sense
daca i think everybody's familiar with
daca again it's actually illegal and
unconstitutional it's created
under obama they created a class that
that actually said if you
fit into this category we're going to
defer and it's renewable
your lawful deportation for being here
illegally
just recently fifth circuit finally came
out and said it's illegal
right finally so you've got tv pra and
daca and then here comes the slammer
it's called fsa the floor settlement
agreement it's a it's a
lower level judicial court decree that
at the end of the day and there's a lot
of there's been several uh
reinterpretations of it over the years
but at the end of the day they said that
if someone sneaks in
breaks into our border is here illegally
and if you're unaccompanied mine or a
family
we cannot detain you for more than 20
days
and during those proceedings we told the
judge
that we can't get through the lawful
deportation proceedings in 20 days
why because we're the most generous
country in the face of the planet and
even though you broke into our country
violated our sovereign laws violated the
rule of law we're still going to give
you more due process
than any country on the face of the
planet but it takes more than 20 days to
do that just says i don't care you got
20 days
catch and release was born that's what
that's what was born out of
and congress failed both republicans and
democrats have failed the american
people
to pass meaningful legislation to
address tvpra
daca or the florida's settlement
agreement and so
that's why in 2019 we were faced with a
crisis
but here's the key though right is that
i think one of the key things we did in
2019 is we were honest with you
right we said we have a crisis
we were honest with american people i
gave more press briefings
i talked to more reporters i opened up
our facilities to anybody who wanted we
had more congressional oversight
we had more congressional delegations
the time that i was there under the
trump administration
than the history of dhs transparent
honesty
information was flowing and we were
honest that we actually had a crisis
and look we did we developed a just a
countless network of initiative policies
and tools that really led to our
successes but let me let me talk about
um just just a couple of what what i
refer to as game changers first the my
protection protocol the remaining mexico
program this was
an absolute game changer what what it
did was
it took that floor settlement agreement
that mandated that we release
in 20 days never to be heard from again
they would never show up i don't care
what anybody tells you
ninety percent of those people that say
her illegally they never complete their
immigration hearings and they remain
here illegally
ninety percent take that to the bank i
don't care what this administration
tells you
so floor settlement grant had to release
the migrant protection protocol
said okay we have to address that
loophole because that's the magnet
that's why they're coming that's why you
saw this huge shift right
and families and uncompany miners from
single adults we historically had seen
and so what we what we saw was with the
remaining mexico program is
we said nope you're not coming in you're
not going to be released you're going to
wait in mexico
go through your proceedings in the u.s
right i know
again don't have to be rocket scientists
what happened
the numbers go down why because we
closed a loophole no longer could you
grab a kid
and that was your passport in the united
states because that's what it was before
that's what catch and release was grab a
kid come to our borders
break in you're rent-free simply because
you are
so-called a family mpp shut
that down it closed uh that loophole it
closed catch and release
and by january 2020 i mean february 2020
you saw illegal immigration dip by 75
percent mpp was absolutely game changer
now
there's a couple one other policy that i
want to talk about
that adds to that though it's called the
aca the asylum cooperative agreements
this is what we entered to in the end
with all three central american
countries guatemala el salvador and
honduras
and what the acas did was really bring
the united states up to the with the
international standards
and i know again this is common sense
right if if you're
actually fleeing persecution which
here's another thing too so there's a
big false narrative out there
the asylum law is very clear you have to
be the victim
of state sponsored persecution for being
the member either based on your
nationality
your ethnicity your your political
affiliation or member of a protected
class
your economic status does not qualify
you for
asylum now look i get it you could be a
living in harsh conditions
conditions none of us would want to live
in i got it but that's
not a valid asylum claim but that's a
false narrative that they're trying to
get the american people to believe
right so the aca said look for those of
you that have a valid claim
rather than give seven thousand dollars
of your life savings
to the cartels and risk your life we
know independent studies show up to 30
percent of women and children are abused
border patrol it's not uncommon for
border child to interview somebody
that has been raped more than once on
the journey here and i can keep going on
and on
rather than do that right why don't you
why don't we mandate that those with
legitimate claims
actually seek relief in the first
country they come to makes sense right
and what that stopped was what referred
to as forum shopping
right and the ultimate they wanted to
get the united states so they were
putting
those with obviously those with with
with uh
fake claims obviously they just wouldn't
get in america but i'm talking about the
ones that had valid claim
they were actually putting their goal
their form shopping
to get to the u.s actually ahead of
their public health and safety
right by waiting and and going to the
cartels
and being smuggled in the united states
instead of getting relief in the first
country you come to
that was also a game changer again that
read led to that significant reduction
the other thing too and i know most of
you have probably heard is title 42
the cdc center for disney's control
title 42
while you know the whole world is going
through a global pandemic and we still
are a new variant
not as deadly but it's it's still
contagious that's going there so we're
not still over the other side of that
um that said the cdc after consultation
with the border security experts said
oh you know what this is a problem so as
an as an effective containment and
mitigation strategy
to further reduce introduction of covet
19 into our country from outside our
borders the cdc
mandated the border patrol no longer
allow
people that break into the country that
have traveled through coveted hot spots
have remained in overcrowded unsanitary
stash houses and tractor trailers for
days and weeks we have no i know ppe we
have no idea what their medical history
is
doesn't just make sense as we're dealing
with the covet in this country
that we say we're not going to let those
people that have illegally entered
into our open air congregate settings
it's going to expose migrants our
personnel and the american people to
covet so they said you apprehend them
process them on the border remove them
immediately and so
that's what we did in my opinion that
has saved
countless american lives and what does
this administration do
unaccompanied minor nope doesn't apply
anymore
hundred thousand hundred thousand
hundred thousand unaccompanied minors
now
they got rid of title 42 on day one for
the unaccompanied minors and we have
experienced a 444
increase in unaccompanied minors april
we saw almost 19 000
that's the highest number of
unaccompanied minors in a single month
in history on the record books
and the last time i checked i'm not a
medical doctor don't want to play one on
tv
but you know unaccompanied minors can
carry covet
just as well as an adult can the other
part to that is
they're actively been talking about
getting rid of title 42 for everybody
but really in
in in essence when it comes to families
they're already not applying it even
though it still applies to families
eighty percent of families are still
being that illegal are still being
released in the united states
um and i think so well title 42 is just
one example i think
i'll bring it back to where i started is
another example of how the correlation
between
illegal immigration and the necessity to
have
give the united states the tools and the
capability to cure our borders against
all threats including infectious
diseases
and the last thing that that i'll
mention um
and then i'll shut up here is i can't
i can't have a conversation when i'm
talking about the wall right
so let's talk about the wall for example
right so let's go back to 2006 secure
fence act
remember remember all those prominent
democratic centers that said oh yeah
we need a wall it's important 650 miles
of wall was built
again we just built a better it was so
needed to stop illegal immigration stop
the drugs from pouring in and secure our
borders
this is absolutely needed we voted for
it bragged about it
and now it's immoral and ineffective now
all of a sudden because president trump
is in in in uh in the white house and
we're building
wall better than ever before look the
wall hands down again
the the strategy that's codified in the
2000 secure offense act
that's been tried and true for decades
infrastructure technology and personnel
wherever that multi-laying multi-phase
strategy
is in place in strategic location every
single
imaginable success measure increases
every single measure it increases
when you have the right
layer of each one of those elements
look at the end of the day the wall is
an effective impedance denial tool
and that's a fact there's historical
data there's analysis it shows that
we presented it again and again and
again and again and this administration
has ignored it
just that just that i think was
yesterday uh senator
lankford published a report on the wall
that said right now this administration
which by the way
i'm gonna i'm gonna say i called it i i
said this from day one
that by stopping building the wall was
actually gonna cost the taxpayers
billions of dollars
to stop building the wall the report
came out and said so far the
uh this fiscal year by biden stopping
the walls cost you taxpayers two billion
dollars
and it continues to cost you three
million dollars a day
not my words that's an official report
so and we knew it we called it
everybody absolutely ignored it um
and one of the last thing they'll say
about the wall i have to say this
because
you know early on i would get this and
like ah it's a
14th century solution to a 21st century
problem right i said yeah so is the
wheel but it still works pretty well
right so it's just sometimes the
arguments are
are just ludicrous so look i'll close
with this
is that unfortunately illegal
immigration clearly has become a
political
uh a weapon in my opinion by the left
one that often
relies on children and the vulnerable
population
that that this administration is
exploiting to further
what they see as a perceived political
benefit it's being weaponized
uh at the expense of american
sovereignty security our future our
well-being
america's national economic security
it absolutely just i can't believe that
i i even say this these days but it
shouldn't be traded for political power
but that this is exactly where we find
ourselves and i think the lesson to be
learned here
for all of us is um uh don't become
complacent
get involved and so people when i look
at
everything that the blind administration
does on the federal level like what can
we do
yeah i don't know i don't have an answer
that cause every single day they double
down
every single week i think i wake up
monday and think okay i'm gonna have a
week to catch up the buy administration
does something else
to screw it up right across the board
to just make it even more dangerous
jeopardize our national security even
more
and so one thing i've been saying is
what i mean by we can get involved
so everybody talks about 2022 right yes
22 matters i got it but we can't wait
till then
that's too late it's too late i mean
this year we are
actually we i i think we're gonna be
we're gonna set historic highs for for
numbers coming across illegal
illegally and again it's not about
illegal immigration it's about border
security they're all interconnected
right
so here's what i'm trying to say is is
uh we were talking a little bit about
this before
but everything from from school board
elections
to mayors right it all matters it all
matters
um i mean look at the defund the police
stuff i'll stop and i won't get too off
uh you know i golf on tangent on that
but but look
get to your state legislators right get
to your state's ags get your state's
governors
it's working look governor abbott in
texas
is leading the way a.g paxton is leading
the way within the within days after
obama administration taken over and he
tried to stop deportations for 100 days
an absolutely illegal executive order
absolutely illegal on its face
a.g pax is the only one that sudany won
and got a nationwide injunction to stop
that
right so we need more of that we've got
other states like uh so so texas right
now he's he's stepping up
he's gonna build the wall and i i will
help him any
imaginable way that i can to continue to
build that wall but he's doing more
he declared a state of emergency right
and so now he's able to take
lower level misdemeanors and raise those
up to higher grade misdemeanors
to actually give real consequences to
those that are breaking
our our our laws and and taking
advantage of the loopholes in our system
he's actually going to apply
consequences you've got governor
desantis now
that's actually stepped up and says he's
going to give resources um
to texas and i'll end with this you know
there was a reporter
i watched the governor desantis uh his
his uh interview
and they're it's ill-informed um
he just didn't always talk about
reporters said well why are you going to
send floridian resources to texas
for a problem in texas right and
he did a great job he said well first of
all states help other states all the
time when they're not infected
to include florida a little thing called
hurricanes right the states send
resources to florida all the time but he
said that's not what we're talking about
here
and he really did a great job of talking
about how every
what i say town city and state is a
border town city and state
what happens on southwest border doesn't
stay there it makes his way to every
neighborhood in this country
and he gave a really good example one of
many that said 90 percent of the meth
that comes into florida
comes from the southwest border right
and i always say
if you have a meth overdose in your city
in your town
and your state i guarantee you it came
from the southwest border
so with that i'm going to shut up and uh
probably talk no i'm not bad huh yeah
okay
all right so um i'll tell you what this
was hard to actually keep with this
short
believe it or not because there's so
much out there so complex but like i
said i
i'd really like to hear questions
so is this just a modern result of the
1965
kennedy johnson law not sure what you're
talking about
i'm not i'm old i'm not that old yet
well you know the immigration laws were
changed in 1965 yeah kennedy
to for the family the results and then
yeah
this is just ground and grown and grown
for 55 years yeah okay so now
yeah so yes and that that's a very good
point and this is another
you know absolute false nerve that's out
there is that root causes
i'm so tired of hearing root causes
right here's what the root causes are
when we open our borders they come right
i mean that's the root causes
look if you look at the difference
between again
let's take april because that's the
highest difference so april this year
april last year 900 increase 900 percent
increase
in illegal immigration in this country
what didn't change during that time
period
the economic conditions in central
america
they didn't change covet code was there
they were still experienced covered like
everybody else
nothing changed in that year but how in
the world
did we get to a 900 increase it's
because our
policies changed so you're spot on every
single time
that there's a shift in our policies at
our border they are exploited
and history points that out
oh sorry i'm supposed to wait for the
microphone
okay do it all right um um
[Music]
um do you think that uh isn't it uh
isn't there
this uh migration issue prima facie
evidence
that the heterosexuals of this world are
creating more life
than those heterosexuals or this world
or you and his organization or this
country are willing to accommodate
so um is it worthwhile to consider
any opposition you if you're concerned
about border security and migration
to uh uh reconsider any obligation
you might have to um
birth control feminism choice on
abortion um
queer acceptance uh and so on especially
noting
a lot of these pro-migrants come from
countries yeah
by conservative christianity
so what i would say that's way outside
my bandwidth or expertise
i'm just a knuckle dragon operator and i
know about border security illegal
immigration that i can tell you is
screwed up
so yeah yes sir
i'm peter humphrey i'm an intelligence
analyst
obviously with the real driver here is
that
democrats are counting on that
a generation hence these people are
overwhelmingly going to vote democratic
in part to replace all the democrats
lost to abortion no doubt
um my concern
is that there's zero chance that isis
al qaeda and the iranian pas de iran
are not seeing this with very clear
spectacles on
and planning accordingly so that amongst
the 2000 or so
middle easterners that we've interdicted
already
there is bound to be a plot in the works
and so my question is does all of this
nonsense
end after the next terror spectacular
yeah so i tell you i'm so glad you asked
this question because i
actually took that out of my comments
because i was there's so much to talk
about so i'm glad you're asking a
question
so i i couldn't agree more with you look
and that's why i keep saying
when you open your border up to one
crisis one threat you're open your
border up to every crisis
that we see the very vast complex set of
threats and i agree with you if you
don't think
that the terrorist organizations who are
just like the cartels
right who are looking for every single
opportunity to exploit to do us harm
they have not wavered in that resolve we
have hardened our defenses among
multiple ways for them to get to this
country and do us harm
but they've changed their ttps as well
as you know and so to think
that they're not looking at our porous
unsecured southwest border
in a way that they could utilize and
exploit to do us harm
i think is naive and absolutely does not
take in consideration the facts in the
history
so i i think that's a real threat and
i'm absolutely concerned about that look
the border cho apprehends
uh on on average uh people from 140
different countries
so what we progressed was with mainly
mexico single adults
and now with everything that i described
it shifted to
families unaccompanied minors mainly
from the northern triangle countries but
it's expanded now
and now this administration and and look
i i i'm going to go to my grave
is not backing off from this they have
opened up our borders and sent a clear
message not just the western hemisphere
but the entire
world that our borders are open so to
think that we're our
national security is not in jeopardy
here is a mistake
in fact that's the genesis you know
that's the genesis of the 2006
secure fence act right in the secure
fence act it talks about securing our
borders
against terrorists or the introduction
of terrorist weapons into the
in the united states via our borders
that's the very premise of the 2006
secure funds act
and now it's not talked about at all
like it doesn't exist
ion here c lee just released a book
called pray
um i don't know if any of you are
familiar with it but she talks about the
the difficulties that the european
countries are facing because the women
in many of the large cities are now
unable to walk safely by themselves as
western women who have been used to that
kind of freedom and the gentleman over
there
responded with the second half of my
question which is um
you know the safety of our communities
now where does it lie i mean
you're talking about closing borders i'm
talking about my niece in the second
cornfield on the left in indiana
has a huge contingent of people being
shoved into her community
and she's trying to do the best she can
to help educate them blah blah blah
but the point is that i suspect
we're going to need a lot of help from
law enforcement agencies
to maintain the kind of order when you
have this mix of
a lot of unaccompanied males who are
criminals
uh who are going to be basically making
us
pray so how do we instigate
our own self-defense other than each of
us having a shotgun in our house
for first first of all by the way i
i am an advocate of weapon ownership so
i i have just a few
um but but here here's what i'll say is
is we have to continue to do stuff like
this
and i know it's a little sappy corny i'm
saying this i'm standing up here but i
believe this because this is about
education and awareness
look the mainstream media is an
extension of the democratic party
i talk to people all the time they are
misinformed not because they're ignorant
but because of the mainstream media is
feeding them lies and misinformation and
spin
and the reality what you just said is
absolutely correct let me give you an
example to bring it home
sanctuary cities sanctuary cities are
the
worst thing for our public safety that
we have and let me give you an example
right now under this administration
because of their priorities they
basically shut down ice
the sheriff's department can arrest a
known gang member
a known gang member that's here
illegally has had multiple entries
and was just arrested for a non-violent
felony
say they robbed your home burglary of a
home they're going to arrest them
they're going to call ice and say we got
one for you guess what ice is going to
say
nope not a priority go ahead and release
them back to your community
that's what we have now so it's not just
that the federal authorities hands are
being tied
but the local law enforcement hands are
being tied
there's a 287g program where local
sheriff's office can actually work
with ice to efficiently remove people
that are here illegally with the
priority being criminals as it's always
been
we have multiple uh sheriffs out there
now
democratic sheriffs that are getting rid
of the 287g program
that the actual nominee for ice this is
why we need to
we need to absolutely resist any single
nomination that dhs is putting forward
right now
the ice nomination is a share he
actually ended the 287g program in his
county
so it's an issue all the way across
and and there one i'm sorry one quick
thing so angel families
have you guys heard of angel families so
angel families are american citizens
that have had a loved one die at the
hands of an illegal alien
how many times how often do you hear
from an angel family
i remember in 2019 i was standing on the
south side of the capitol
with a bunch of angel families while
with some republican leadership while
the democrats
were on the north side holding up
pictures of federal agents that hadn't
gone without a check
in two weeks that shows you where we're
at i'm not saying that's great either
but
holy cow really when is it last time
when was the last time this president
this president
or dhs secretary marcus went and
actually spoke
to an angel family who lost a loved one
at the hands of an illegal
immigrant illegal alien in a sanctuary
city that was released
that should have been deported how many
times that happened
zero sorry i get fired up
and this will be our last question thank
you um
from the time of the inauguration of
biden
it took him a long time to
react to the border then it took him a
long time
to assign kamala harris to take care of
the problem
then it took a long time for her to
decide whether or not she's going to go
to the border
and when she did get on a plane she
didn't go to the border
that's right and then she came back
here's my question
how do you see her playing out this
role of solving the border crisis
as the numbers continue to rise she's
going to try to avoid it at
all costs and address political optics
only and not a single substantive issue
her action will come from her mouth
that's what's going to happen
because that's what she's already doing
when you've anointed the vice president
as the czar
then that's the person that's in charge
now that we have the same thing in a
positive way on the trump administration
with covey
vice president pence was annoyed to the
the
the chair of if you will uh for the kova
task force
and so even the hs secretary then would
report that's how it should go
but it's a joke we know it's all
substance over form
you know look we know the only reason
why she went there
the only reason why she went there is
because president trump went
right i mean she had no plans to go and
then president trump said he's going to
go and
all of a sudden she went three days
before he did right
and by the way i went with president
trump to the border and
he here was a unique difference we we
first we actually went to the border
right we actually got we actually went
outside of the air-conditioned space
right we actually went to the epicenter
of the crisis now don't get me wrong
all 2000 miles are busy all you got 190
000 a single month
all nine sectors on the southwest border
are busy but if you really understand
the truth and reality of any crisis
you go to the epicenter you know jordan
when when when president biden went
to see the the condo that collapsed he
didn't go three blocks away
right you go to see the actual crisis to
understand it
president trump and governor abbott
actually went to the epicenter of the
rio grande valley
where the majority of illegal entries in
the crisis is happening
and he actually went outside of air
conditioned space and actually went to
the border and actually went to the wall
um and so look at the end of the day
um i i i think they're the same
dhs secretary marcus he's lying to you
he is lying
and remember he was the deputy secretary
uh
um uh under obama and it was then that
secretary jay johnson
remember his quote he said and i was the
chief of the border troll then
right so i was the chief of the border
troll in the obama administration
working for jay johnson you know
reporting to then
deputy secretary mayarkas when jay
johnson said
a thousand illegal immigrants a day is a
bad day
a thousand we're getting six to seven
thousand a day
right and they haven't done a single
thing to address the flow
all they're doing is expanding and
facilitating and playing the shell game
now not only i give a quick story about
how they move migrants from one facility
to the next
they're flying families and uncompany
minors in the middle of the night
to cities all throughout the united
states right
why because they're trying to hide
what's physically happening on the
border
they're just getting better at releasing
they're not and so it's
it's an absolute shell game so they're
not doing anything to stem the flow
they're just getting better
at facilitating and releasing people
i'll give you a quick story
adt sorry so alternative to detention
so you come here you break into our
country here illegally we give you an
ankle bracelet
just like we do any other criminal in
the united states that we don't put
behind bars right because it's supposed
to inspire you to
show up right um because you're wearing
that bracelet if not then we know we are
going to get you
this administration now which was fully
supportive of that
fully supportive of that because they
didn't want anybody to be detained so
they really loved adt
and now they're saying well those
bracelets are demeaning
what we'd like to do is said to get rid
of that and let's give them a cell phone
i'm not making it up i'm not making up
that's what's happening
so when you ask me what vice president
harris is gonna do
nothing but make the problem worse in
fact early on i was one
a little bit tongue-in-cheek but i'm
serious i was like i hope she doesn't go
to the border
because there's nothing anything
substance she's just gonna make it worse
and and this current
dhs secretary he's the same thing he's
he he's absolutely
i mean remember he was one of the the
authors of daca he is a full
open border uh a secretary he's lying to
you about the border secure and open and
could go on and on
this administration is not going to do
anything to secure this border
they're just going to hide it from you
going to cover the policies continue to
do it because
the two things for me they see a
perceived political benefit in two ways
one is they're playing the long game so
they see a potential increase in house
seats in the census why
because now illegal aliens are counted
in the census so that's a very real
threat and then the other part of that
they see that every individual that they
find illegal alien that they find a
pathway to citizenship
they believe that's going to equate to a
democratic vote
that's where we're at and what one we're
not saying i know i'll shut up
is that so the the there's a dirty
little secret about amnesty
right guess who guess who's the only
folks that care about amnesty democrats
democrats because again they think that
the pathway of citizenships are going to
equate to a democratic vote
guess who doesn't care about amnesty
illegal aliens today
they do not care if you ask the illegal
alien because we do
if we allowed you to illegally enter the
country and stay
work illegally and not be deported but
you can never be a citizen or vote
guess what they say i'm in and guess
what
that's what we're doing right now right
they don't amnesty
being a citizen or vote that that
doesn't even break their top 10
right now right they're economic
migrants they just want to come here
have a better life
they want to have a better car better
house god bless them
but they need to follow the law yep
you